thank you
[Music]
this is one of those weird stories where
the facts are different every one of the
uh different Outlets you look up reading
about it so I'm not gonna sweat the
details but the technique in Wisconsin
there's like a hospice there's a patient
there an old man he's suffering from
frostbite so his like legs are kind of
becoming necrotic you got a gangrene
yeah it starts to rot out
um how come Wim Hof never gets frostbite
that fool's [__] Gangsta dude he
walked the Himalayas Barefoot swaming
man this guy's a little [__] I should
be like you should have learned the Wim
Hof method do you think Wim Hof really
did that [__] though or is he like
putting on shoes and then like taking
pictures with his shoes off like I don't
ever believe that [__] you don't think
so did he take a group of people and
they also did he did yeah yeah really
all True Believers are Wim Hof maybe he
has dude he probably has those feet that
look like shoes those shoes like the
hobbits the Vibrams slides into those
things the separated toes nobody knows
yeah yeah
yeah so this dude
um he has like a care nurse like most
hospices do
care nurse we all know is not a doctor
cannot make severe calls on what to do a
lot of times she'll have to take orders
and just kind of well during covet they
sure had a lot of opinions
that I think constitutes medical advice
at the time I was like wow that seems
like medical advice to me but
I think during Kobe they all were
promoted to doctors yeah yeah yeah if
they showed up they're a doctor their
head surgeon yeah if they showed up
they're mostly dancing on tick tock
yeah so there's a dude he's got um his
legs are rotten she decides that she's
gonna go and take the initiative and
chop his foot off herself what what a
Good Samaritan so she did it
and Steve is right dude those nurses why
did you do that you can't do that you
need a doctor's orders and she ended up
uh they found out she told one of her
friends that she wanted to display it at
her family's taxidermy shop whoa so she
did it for selfish reasons oh yeah but
she that's a good term old people that
it wasn't for selfish reasons that it
was because she didn't want him to have
like not have dignity or something see I
don't like that I don't like it when
someone does it for themselves but then
they think they're they're like masking
and I'm trying to help him yeah that's
exactly what she did and then the funny
thing is that she was like oh it's fine
like he it was so like necrotic that he
he probably didn't feel it and then they
someone else asked him and he was like
no I felt it it hurt the whole time oh
what the [__] and what was the doctor
like we could have saved that foot I
think they knew they they couldn't but
it wasn't really her place to do the
chop chop because it was it was really
[__] like it was they said it was only
on by tendons but does she even know how
to do it right at that point I think
anyone can kind of oh you get nail
clippers
I mean a cut is a card is a cut is a
girl so what was he doing like walking
around Barefoot in the snow was he
trying to be like Wim Hof no I think I
think uh they don't they haven't said
but a lot of time you can you can get
frostbite not from doing like a snow
Excursion at a at a late age in your
life you could just get it from being
cold oh man it's also that just lack of
blood circulation so then it can't like
warm itself up and stuff like that I bet
you he has diabetes
yeah they probably take bets at the
hospice like that maggots in my uncle's
foot because he has diabetes like crazy
they found maggots inside
like oh why because they died and then
the Flies were eating his dead foot yeah
the foot's like gone [__] [__]
speaking medical terms
take walks man you need to take walks
when you're old you gotta be like the
old people that walk like this with
their hands in the back and then they're
just they look they they stare at
homeless people they stare at kids
[__] playing at the park [__]
pigeons are their best friends those are
the healthiest old people yeah they look
pretty ugly yeah here's a sad quote um
when she said that no he didn't appear
to be in any pain this guy's actual
sentence was that he that I felt
everything and it hurt very bad
correct Miss quote this she did she
clean it up right
Gang Green
duck Rose
a moment to actually tell her like I
don't know I have what like you know
what there's a huge Silver Lining to
this what is it I love these yeah well
number one you already said that uh
everybody basically already knew who
would have to cut it off anyway so there
would have been not really an outcome
that was different from physically but
at least now he's gonna win this lawsuit
he's dead
not all the information is present
I mean that's kind of the way hospices
go at least his family will get the
money well his family was murdered last
week at least the nurse got the foot to
show her Taxidermy yeah crying like oh
[__] this is a time so the B plot ends
well yeah yeah her plot ends well right
yeah and she's like anybody want to ask
me about the leg anybody anybody anybody
is pretty much said yeah to the Moon he
died because of this no it's a hospice
he was gonna die no matter what yeah
hospice is just like hey man let's
morphing you up and give you a good
send-off you know it's like they know
he's gonna die but that's what makes it
weird is that she really didn't need to
cut it yeah she could have left it on
him right so she just put him through
his whole himself I mean couldn't she so
I guess his family could throw a lawsuit
because that's yeah that's stupid yeah
yeah it's to not feel pain right correct
so that would be the yeah instead
opposite you probably shouldn't chop his
leg off so the last moment he was like I
felt that if you're gonna make these
claimsical what she should have done is
after you he's died she goes hey we
don't need that y'all gonna you're gonna
use this yeah he's gonna need this leg
let me use it or that's the right way to
do things you wait till your friend's
full and then you go you're gonna eat
that wow oh my God because there's
always like some [__] up Spurs here
from like hospice or like Elder Care
when you hear someone that just cut off
some guy's leg as a nurse she probably
did some other crazy [__] that no one
knows about while he was alive too she's
in the Taxidermy those people should be
investigated anyway yeah dude yeah you
know who else was in the Taxidermy why
you pointing me Jeffrey Dahmer there you
go investigate them all open the books
on all of them check it out just look
into it hand us the list Hannah's cousin
made that famous Fox the ugly Fox
Taxidermy Fox oh the one that's all yeah
the one that's a meme that's your friend
no that's a cousin oh wow
I didn't even know that was a real fox
it's a Taxidermy Fox cool
it's the most useless Factor thank you
thank you thank you for that
now you know
that's so good that is I think it's a
cool facts
look at the [__] fox now God damn it
I hate that thing I just want to think
it's terrified in general though it's
funny he looks like one of those foxes
that are like oh you're the stupid one
with mange or something yeah like the
three dragon meme where one of them
looks all dumb
people it's so creepy and the way it's
positioned it is really [__] there's
one of a rat that's like I don't know if
it's a sculpture but a Taxidermy but
it's all [__] up in one of his ears
are all chewed off and then my homies
always send it to me saying it to me
because both of yours are all [__] up
I don't get it you're talking about this
one right
yeah that's the one two whoa your cousin
knows that
my cousin made that
yo are those eyes
got eyes like original or they're googly
they're they're painted on
think of your top five questions for
this we'll knock them out go ahead it's
a good stance my first question is the
eyes are they real or fake
it looks like a kid's face huh yeah yeah
yeah
so yeah I thought a fox would be more
like that like a dog but it's like a cat
it looks like a cat face
dude there's so many things that
um let me ask this why did you take that
chair
oh it's cool I know the guy that was
Hannah's cousin is his Hannah's cousin I
never met her before what is that first
which one oh this all right you want
another one no no I don't but can we
stop this is terrifying oh oh my god
dude that's not even close to being the
worst one no I want to see is it by the
same artist no I don't know we'll have
to ask Hannah because it is it's
Hannah's cousin
I'll make it stop
it stop I don't know dude the upper lip
is like what's the deal with that I
think I guess by The Joker dude from
animated series [__] wild so she she
specifically works on the run of the
crew
oh man that's pretty bad
[Music]
laughs